eric loret bonjour bonjour monsieur
bonjour à tous les auditeurs et
auditrices de marty une première alors
le groupe politique le marin autrement a
désigné donc son candidat aux élections
municipales et contre toute attente ce
n'est pas je saint germé dans le nom
était souvent prononcée justement
jusqu'il ya quelques semaines mais c'est
bien vous eric et l'aurait donc qu'ils
allaient porter en tête de liste les
couleurs de ce groupe le marin autrement
je saint-germé pourquoi parce que
lui-même était deuxième adjoint au maire
du marin enfin il l'est encore
donc on l'a dit est pressenti pour mener
la liste finalement ce sera vous membre
de la majorité municipale puisque vous
êtes quatrième adjoint au maire alors
incontestablement ce scrutin aux marins
revêtent un caractère particulier du
fait des tracasseries judiciaires qu'ont
connus récemment la municipalité et le
maire sortant par rapport à un marché
public concernant une partie du
fonctionnement sur eux sur le port de
plaisance comment le quatrième adjoint
que vous êtes encore eric loret et le ré
et le candidat que vous êtes aussi donc
vit cette situation pour moi monsieur
cette situation est en cours
d'instruction
il s'agit aujourd'hui d'instruire une
affaire puisque vous voulez faire je
parle pas de la faire je parle du
contexte que ça a donné pour le scrutin
la sphère il s'agit pas de la refaire
vous avez raison elle est en instruction
d'accord mais sur le climat l'ambiance
que ça a instauré à la veille du scrutin
aux marins
je pense que les marines oise et les
marinois sont très sereins nous le
sommes tous d'ailleurs tous les
candidats du marin sont très sereins
parce que nous avons le respect de l'un
des uns et des autres chacun a choisi
son camp
chacun a choisi sa façon de mener sa
campagne et chacun aussi rester sur ses
lignes politiques
aujourd'hui et jusqu'au 14 mars prochain
je serai encore 4ème adjoint responsable
la caisse des écoles
mais il était évident de par mes
origines politiques que j'allais
conduire une liste et que j'allais avec
des camarades parce que nous appartenons
aussi en grande partie où j'allais dire
au canal historique du bbm du marin le
alors on va y venir mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que est-ce qu'on en parle
beaucoup
d'ores et déjà parce que nous sommes
maintenant à moins de deux mois
quasiment du premier tour des
municipales
oui est-ce que la situation particulière
du marin avec les faits qui sont passés
récemment est ce que on en parle
beaucoup est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que c'est quelque chose qui
va être le thème principal ou un des
thèmes principaux de la campagne des
municipales
je pense qu'on ne pourra pas l'éviter
mafieux je pense qu'on ne pourra pas
l'éviter parce qu'inévitablement les
marins les maris noir ont besoin de la
vérité
ils ont besoin de savoir ils ont besoin
de connaître et donc le bilan de la
mandature est quelque peu entachée d'une
manière ou d'une autre
quel que soit le jugement qui sera
prononcé il s'agit pas de la présomption
d'innocence vaut mais sa marque quand
même votre campagne vous la majorité
municipale pour la majorité municipale
pas pour toute la majorité municipale
puisque je pense que tous les adjoints
que nous sommes et les conseillers que
nous sommes n'ont pas tous été associé à
cette affaire je pense que les gens qui
ont été associés ont été interpellés
entendue écoutée mise en examen allez
voir incarcéré mais pour ce qui concerne
les autres adjoints et les autres
conseillers municipaux pour ma part à ce
que je sache
aujourd'hui personne n'a été interpellé
maintenant je ne suis pas dans les
confidences du juge et je le serai donc
faire son travail bien on ne s'étendra
pas davantage
en revanche une chose est certaine c'est
que vous allez affronter
autre première adjointe la première
adjointe du conseil municipal du marin
la première adjointe du groupe
majoritaire event reid
oui alors
luttes intestines au sein de la majorité
mais aussi laurent pas du tout pas du
tout nous n'avons pas la même origine
politique
vous savez pour soutenir la candidate
elle et pml et au ppm aussi madame tritz
non ça je ne sais pas voulu de l'entré
jeu n'aura pas qu'elle le soit vie
d'accord vous d'accord pour ça que vous
avez parlé de canal historique etc
vous savez très bien joué vous savez
très bien comme moi même qu'il ya eu un
conflit où un conflit larvé en train un
nouveau ppm qui est celui d'aimé césaire
est un ancien ppm qui celui qui
s'appelait parti progressiste
martiniquais d'une parti progressiste
martiniquais
donc pour vous alors qu'abby oui le
baliser historique c'est celui dr k bis
et un nouveau balisiers a été créé c'est
celui d'aimé césaire qui a été créé à la
limite à l'opportunité pour venir à ces
élections mais je me disais non luttes
intestines je vous ai posé la question
vous me dites pas vraiment non pas
vraiment c'est pas vous considérez pas
vous moi je ne considère par là qu'il
s'agit d'une lutte intestine puisque
nous n'avons pas les mêmes origines
politiques même si nous nous retrouvons
au sein du parti progressiste
martiniquais
vous savez que par exemple lors des
élections législatives le parti
progressiste martiniquais appelait à
voter la france insoumise les verts ou
bien les socialistes les dirigeants
marin certains d'entre eux tout au moins
appeler à voter pour la liste de la
reine donc par conséquent vous voyez
bien que la diversité de l'équipe en
place se réunissaient autour de lully
prm qui était d'union démocratique
populaire pour le renouveau du marin
mouvement qui a été créée dans les
années 80 pour permettre à rodolphe
désiré d'accéder au pouvoir mais que par
la suite les différents membres qui sont
venus composer oui on va pas refaire
toute l'histoire vous me dire qu'à pas
de luttes intestines mais bon ça y
ressemble à un petit peu dernière
question eric et leur et que préconisez
vous donc vous le candidat aux élections
municipales aux marins pour mieux
développer l'économie du territoire de
cette ville et apporter du mieux être
aux marines oiseaux marino le marin
autrement le marin terre d'excellence à
un programme
c'est un programme qui aujourd'hui
considèrent que nous sommes restés 36
années tourné vers la mer il trente six
années à consentir tous les efforts
financiers vers la politique maritime
nous considérons que le marin et
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que nous
l'appelons terre d'excellence
c'est aussi un territoire c'est aussi
des hommes et des femmes donc par
conséquent notre priorité sera de mettre
en oeuvre un programme urgent à terme
d'équipements publics
bien évidemment nous pensons à
l'économie bien évidemment nous pensons
que l'attractivité de la ville de
continue mérite d'être soutenu mais nous
considérons également que nous a tous
maritime ils permettent aussi d'aller
beaucoup plus loin
merci eric leray d'avoir répondu à nos
questions dans ce sens qu'a dit spécial
municipal avec à la réalisation
audry calixte je vous remercie